welcome back to the show i'm not david s
pumpkins
today's program will remind all you kids
out there be careful what you wish for
do you want a loyal best buddy or a pot
of gold at the end of the rainbow
be my guest or rather be their victim
in one corner we have chucky the
torturous toy trickster
and his opponent the limericking
limestone laden leprechaun
you may feel some pain tis a pity i
forgot me novocaine
these two have transcended the confines
of the horror movie genre and have
permanently cemented themselves in both
the pop culture lexicon
and our nightmares heck you can even
catch them on every football
saturday and sunday sports are the
ultimate escape
but there is no running from these tiny
tinsel town pairs
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one
box office round two tomato meter slash
audience score round three creation
story
and then i'll do a wild card round
that's going to prove this is the
ultimate duel of diminutive devils
on the line a fresh pot of gold against
the toys r us
shopping spree even though i'm fairly
certain jeffrey the giraffe doors are
closed
and that gold let's face it it's
probably just foil and casing for subpar
milk chocolate
hey i ain't complaining chucky's got his
game face ready
the leprechaun wore his best river
dancing boots so let's get it on
it's show time he won't beat me
because i have a love for a gun
round one box office in past episodes of
versus when we talk box office
it's usually boffo billions of dollars
are tossed around with regularity
and while i don't get to keep any of it
it's no secret why some other franchises
have remained so popular
money talks but for child's play and
leprechaun movies
uh yeah let's not start looking at
winter homes in florida just yet
to date only the first two of the eight
leprechaun films have been given a
proper theatrical release
remember when he danced an irish jig on
the moon or sang about the multiple
definitions of booty and leprechaun in
the hood
yet we enjoyed those on home video the
franchise has just grossed 24 million
dollars in domestic coin making for an
average of 12 million per outing
but even if we give the little leper
that doesn't sound healthy
a wide release for all eight films
chances are he still can't
play with the chuckster i want respect
child's play came out in the 80s the
decade before sentient toys became our
cuddliest pixar pals
and sliced its way to an impressive 78
million domestic hall
sequels and more profit would follow
until the curse of chucky
and then the cult of chuck he decided to
head directly to video update
that was the williamsburg virginia
version of blockbuster
i still owe them late fees i can't think
of a
thing to say all told six of the eight
child's play flicks sold tickets at
movie theaters and they combined for a
286 million dollar franchise tag
that makes for a 47.6 billion per flick
average
somehow that still surpasses the gross
of the recent reboot
featuring mark hamill as the voice of
chucky which finished its run at 29
million dollars
leprechaun can compete with that number
but given the chuckster's head start in
the horror heyday of the 1980s
and his consistent presence in theaters
it's an easy round one victory
so easy you might say it's child's play
what you're right i deserve to have a
green goblin curse me forevermore for
making that dad joke
don't [ __ ] with the chuck round two
tomato meter slash audience score okay
leprechaun it's your lucky day because
now that we're done with the finances
let's talk about your pot of gold have i
mentioned that i won't be gold
specifically how did critics feel about
your extreme methods in protecting said
treasure
oh it's not good uh here's the bright
spot the underappreciated leprechaun in
the hood is at 30
and leprechaun returns the most recent
entry in the franchise
has the highest percentage of all his
movies at 44.
we're trending upward which is my
sugar-coated way of saying
here's the bad news three of the
leprechaun flicks
are at zero percent zero
point zero the one that started it all
and introduced us to jennifer anderson
pre-racial cut
is just at 23 so this all makes for an
average film score
of 16.6 percent but hey these are horror
movies they never sit well with
the critics said the person who doesn't
have a teleprompter in front of them
i know because child's play movies do
pretty darn well
half of the films in the franchise get
this are fresh
that's four movies about a murderous
doll that critics said yep that's
cinema what are you looking at
71 is the score for the original flick
that started it all
then cursive chucky broke the curse of
direct to red box and earned a 76
percent
cultive chucky then set the all-time
high at 79
the most recent reboot is also fresh at
63 percent so
it's been a nice turnaround for chuck
his lowest movie is child's play 3 at 29
but overall he's still on the outskirts
of fresh town
with a 55 average for eight movies
this doll can kill you with a knife or
the kind words movie reviewers have
given him over the years
you [ __ ] with me okay okay but that
audience score has got to favor the
leprechaun right
i mean he was referenced in wayne's
world garth i'm the
africa cool it okay unfortunately it
appears most of the audience
sided with garth leprechaun does better
in this frame
but his 30 average is still dwarfed oh
sorry about that chucky's 53
average and the closest the irish troll
gets to fresh
is a respectable 48 for leprechaun
returns
which if you're keeping score at home is
two percent higher than constantine
starring keanu reeves
sorry jacqueline coley maybe rotten
tomatoes is
wrong enjoy our podcast wherever you
listen to stuff fine
all right already child's play takes
round two and it appears the leprechaun
has just about reached the end of his
rainbow
i am chucky the killer dog
and i dig it round three
creation story the fighting irish
football team has been mythologically
great at late game comebacks and if
leprechaun wants to prove he's the next
joe montana
it'll take one convincing tall tale ah i
said tall
my bad about three foot six three four
six
yep but but i make up for it in other
areas
creator mark davis wanted to make a
horror movie you know what inspired him
yep lucky charms he saw an ad for the
cereal which i ate not two hours ago
and the rest is cinematic history [ __ ]
you lucky charms
so while the actual genesis of the movie
franchise itself is giggle worthy
the war of the leprechaun is dead
serious each movie spins a slightly
different version of the tale
our villain can be anywhere from 600 to
2000 years old
originally he got his pot of gold stolen
chased it across the atlantic to north
dakota where he got boxed in for 10
years before escaping in go-karts
since then his mission has varied from
revenge like in back to the hood
to finding a bride as seen in part two
he went to los angeles to achieve the
bride goal
good luck pal the line starts right
behind me
something new something old
let's be together on leprechaun's goal
based on the war and origins he may
actually be a god
or at least a being with supernatural
powers ones that keep him in statue form
until a medallion is removed
from the adorable lawn ornament exterior
it's up to keep up with all that
creativity but chucky doesn't care
his story has remained comparatively
steadfast but no less compelling
the lakeshore strangler managed to
transfer his soul into a good guide doll
by way of voodoo just before he died the
strangler's name
charles lee ray why because of course it
is
never trust someone who goes by three
names they could be a killer
i'm not ashamed to be a killer i'm proud
of it
it's not an addiction it is a choice
and it is not something that you should
have to hide in the closet
even the good ones keegan michael key
murders us all with his delightful
comedy
and david lee roth slaughters rock
arenas around the globe
i don't even trust f scott fitzgerald he
killed jay gaspy
right as for the old sport chucky the
magic isn't just in his creation it's in
his multiple resurrections
yeah he's been brought back to life by
electrical malfunctions
stitching some of his blood falling into
a vat used to make more
good guy dolls that's a bad day at the
plant and in the most recent version
ai was the cause of him coming back to
life don mancini is the genius behind
child's play
he wrote seven of the scripts and
directed three films in the franchise
and while the origin story of his
beloved evil creation gets points for
consistency
the greatness of leprechaun lies in the
fact that none of us really know how he
got here in the first place
and thus how the hell do we game plan in
kc returns
both evil entities have proven they'll
never really die
but if we're going off of who had the
most interesting birth i have to
apologize to everyone in new orleans
particularly that one woman that worked
in a store in the french quarter that
i'm pretty sure cursed me after a comedy
show
voodoo is powerful and i respect it but
what are all the kids trying to take
me lucky charms leprechaun wins round
three
and is back in the game because you know
the left
is the real o g and now it's time for
the wild card round
iconic moments this is where the luck of
the irish could come up huge
even for a monster that needs an epipen
if he's around four leaf clovers
say we want about lackluster box office
or rotten tomato meters
both chucky and the leprechaun are
firmly entrenched in the cultural
zeitgeist for a reason
they've given us plenty of highlights
over the years
hello andy going back to the first
child's play
chuck has always had a flare for the
dramatic he used a voodoo dog to kill dr
death and as impressive as the start as
that is what i consider to be the most
iconic
would be how he met his bride to be it's
the classic story we were all told as
kids
grandpa dumped a tv into the bathroom to
off grandma
the movie playing on said television at
the time bride of frankenstein
it works on so many levels hey raggedy
ann
you looked in the mirror lately now's
not the time to get
picky chucky has wreaked havoc on folks
with his go-to weapon of choice
a butcher knife are you born with a
knife super glued onto your hand or what
but occasionally he goes to the bench
and calls in
say an axe in cursive chucky a yardstick
in child's play too
or how about child's play 3 when he
throws the proverbial kitchen sink at
this poor fella
is that a golf club and a yo-yo
major points for creativity buddy
nothing like a strangulation
to get the circulation going his
counterpart is also a gifted improviser
as the leprechaun has utilized
everything from a pogo stick
to a lawnmower blade to make memorable
deaths in his movies
a personal favorite is when leprechaun
in outer space
sneaks his essence into a guy's body via
p then transfers himself into another
person
when those two morons decide to do the
nasty
holy [ __ ] and they call me
sick sadly this is not the first time
i've had to remind folks watching this
show
do not have sex in space why is this so
difficult
it should be like day one of nasa school
thank you class
see you tomorrow and we'll talk about
how to not pee on a tiny corpse
it's a dead body not snow let that be a
lesson to your life
besides that flick being my favorite one
to bring up at dinner parties
it also features a lightsaber kill
fitting
because who plays the leprechaun yep
star wars veteran
warwick davis he borrowed that laser
sword from the latest voice of chucky
and never gave it back but my favorite
gruesome kill in any of the leprechaun
films
has got to be in the zero percent fresh
part three
when a poor woman combusts in front of
our eyes
or in part two when a guy gets a pot of
gold in his tummy
or in back in the hood when some poor
sap meets his demise at the hands of a
bong wielding leprechaun
look out californians that could happen
to any one of us
each fella has a wicked smart sense of
humor chucky loves to go to the laugh
and the leprechaun kicked off his
franchise
featuring a wheelchair chase scene that
rivals the rascal scooter chase from
seinfeld
both these are horror movies so what's
the truly most
terrifying scene from each set for
chucky it's when we all find out
he ain't running on batteries it's in
the very first film and when that
knowledge meets the fact that he
survived a gunshot
look out sometimes i scam myself
this rampaging ruckspin is going to be
running with the devil long after the
energizer bunny peters out for good old
greeny
i'm going to go with more recent
offerings it's a toss-up between
leprechaun returns when he pops out of
poor ozzy's stomach
or in origins when he shows the world he
may be old but he still plays video
games
fatality chucky is great and has given
us a closet full of memories to cherish
but the links the leprechaun has gone
for us cannot be denied
the trip from ireland is worthy of
consideration but then to go to the hood
twice and outer space again the
leprechaun went to outer space
and flattened a guy it's so gnarly
leprechaun gets the win in the wild card
round
and we got us a tied ball game i'm the
man of green
come to do no good left in the hood come
to do no good
left in the hood come to do no good yes
it's been a back and forth
slugfest that has resulted in a tie but
did you tune in to see a draw
where do you think chucky and leprechaun
are just going to shake hands buddy up
and go live with annabelle in the next
great sitcom
dull babies is filmed before a live
studio audience
it's a rare condition uh uber ain't
gonna sit for that and i know you folks
want a winner so here we go with one
final question
who'd win in a fight leprechaun is much
older but that could prove wiser against
his younger opponent
chucky does have just as many movies
under his overalls and although he
doesn't have the frequent flyer miles of
his elder
he does have voodoo that could
counteract leprechaun's magic
and if chunky gets his hands on the gold
it might further reduce leprechaun's
powers
both fellas tend to have a weakness for
the ladies but it's my estimation that
leprechaun has more holes in his game
than chuck
four leaf clover iron eating count
chocula instead of lucky charms
chucky has assets that work against the
leprechaun
and he's got a whole cult and a loving
bride that could jump into the fracas
binging the leprechaun movies is an
ellis family st patrick's day tradition
but if he ever runs across chucky all
the green in the world won't save him
from getting pinched
no shame in losing to a doll leprechaun
especially one voiced by brad dorith
you know i love being me and i love my
job
i'm [ __ ] infamous chucky wins but
that's just according to my book
and i can barely read now it's your turn
my lovely viewers
comment below and vote with your pick is
it the box office king chucky
or the magical mystery of the leprechaun
i can't wait to have somebody else read
me your take
and i'll leave you with what your senior
quote should have been
i'll take it from you homie you'll see
because you know the leprechaun
is the real og
you